congratulations scp explained fans
you've just scored yourselves front row
siege to the freak show hey don't be so
nervous i know clowns don't necessarily
have the best rep these days thank you
very much john wayne gacy and stephen
king but i guarantee you i'm not like
the other clowns at herman follow circus
of the disquieting i'm as human as you
are well okay that's potentially
debatable depending on how stingy you
are with your definitions of what
exactly counts but we'll get into that
later see i'm what they call an
anomalous humanoid known to the eggheads
who work for miss scp foundation as
scp-2094
object class euclid whatever the heck
that means my friends call me bonnie on
account of the fact that's my government
name but if you're a fan of the circus
you probably know me better by my stage
name motormouth pretty fitting nickname
ain't it i tried to make bonnie the
bottomless happen in the early days of
my career but it wasn't catchy enough to
stick then one day my buddy quincy
threatened to barf a swarm of bees on my
face if i didn't shut my mother mouth
and that's been my stage name ever since
now that we're properly introduced
you're probably wondering what cool
tricks i have up my sleeve to get me
that nifty scp designation well it's not
because of my height and manual
dexterity my juggling skills my
accordion praying prowess or even my
nearly perfect impression of jane fonda
as barbarella so if you guessed any of
those you're way off base see i'm the
subject of a quote unquote spatial
anomaly accessible through my mouth and
my throat in plain english i've got a
second stomach anything i swallow
disappears into a pocket dimension made
of anomalously elastic intestinal tissue
where it's stored until i need it again
if there's a limit to how much i can
store in there i haven't found it yet
the amount of stuff in there has no
effect on my overall weight or my
ability to move once it's in there it's
just kind of gone until i want it back
on top of that my lower jaw can be
stretched up to six feet that's two
meters for those of you weirdos who use
the metric system in any direction so in
addition to being a juggler and a clown
i also made the killing as a geek at
herman fellas circus i don't mean geek
as in owned a signed james t kirk funko
pop that's still in mint condition i
mean the sense of somebody who gets paid
the weird junk as a form of performance
although i have been accused by some of
being both now you're probably thinking
motormouth my power my good body there's
so many careers you could have gone into
with that very specific set of skills
garbage disposal one-man moving band
service left luggage attendant at grand
central station sky's the limit man well
sure but i love the circus they're the
only family i've ever got in this world
that came to them when i was just a why
that punk kid of eight years old and
they took me in like i was their own
flesh and blood yeah believe it or not i
wasn't actually born into the circus
life a lot of circus and performing arts
folks are born into the industry born in
a costume trunk as they say but
unfortunately that's not me i was born
in new york city on april 10th 1976. my
dad had took off long before i showed up
leaving me in the care of my dear old
mom my special abilities manifested
early and my mom recognized them right
away you know how little kids are always
putting things in their mouths right
it's cute when it's a block or an action
figure but less so when it's the entire
coffee table yeah my mom was fully aware
of what i could do and she hated my guts
for it not only had a baby daddy flown
the coop but the kid she was racing was
a freak of nature who she could barely
stand to look at and trust me the
feelings of resentment were totally
mutual one of my favorite pastimes as a
youngster was to go out and find as many
small animals as i could get my little
hands on then go back inside where mom
was laid out on the pilot chair sleeping
off one of her special grown-up
headaches she got from downing a bottle
and a half of a special grown-up juice i
made like i was going to innocently ask
her a question smiling one of those
adorable little eight-year-old smiles
then instead of saying anything i just
barf up a couple dozen rats onto her lap
despite how much i hated living at home
it never occurred to me that i could
leave i was a pretty wide-eyed kid monk
kept me isolated from the wider world i
guess had a fear that i'd eat somebody
but one night as i was going to bed i
met manny who's manny
come on if you know anything about the
circus of disquieting then you know
manny don't you guys already have a
video on that manny's short for the man
with the upside down face he was herman
fuller's right hand in charge of a lot
of the backstage stuff including shall
we say
talent acquisition who knows how he
figured out where i was or that i could
even do what i do but just like magic he
showed up in my window should i have
been worried that a man with an upside
down face was at my window probably but
i guess i was just happy to see someone
who was more of a freak than me manny
offered me a place in a real family
where i wouldn't be cooped up he said
that freaks belonged out in the world
sharing their talents making people
laugh and cry and puke all over the
place i didn't hesitate i took him up on
this offer mommy dearest was so deep in
the drink that she didn't even notice i
left and that was that from that day
forward i was a member of hermann
fuller's family i never looked back not
even once now it may also surprise you
to know that i wasn't always the picture
of confidence i am today my first job
with the circus was as the human clown
car as a kid i didn't have a lot of
stage presence and i didn't talk much so
the natural thing to do was to send me
out to the ring and let the clown
through come mouching out of my mouth to
the surprise and delight of the audience
i learned juggling from a guy named
scythe he was a human pin cushion but
like most of us at hermann fuller his
abilities were way beyond what you'd see
in any common or gotham circus scythe
was incredible at what he did you could
stick a shiv in every square inch of
this guy and he'd never bat an eye
thorough jerk though and awful with kids
so how he got the job of training me in
the ways of the juggler is totally
beyond me if i so much as talked out of
turn he'd beam me in the head with a
juggling pin not hard just enough to
hurt i know that sounds bad but at least
it toughened me up i think scythe was
jealous of me in hindsight i was
unnatural and i think he saw me as you
know some kind of threat scythe
eventually died and the fire stunt gone
wrong i owed a funeral for him but i was
busy that day clowning i learned from a
guy called scruffy mcgrubbins good old
scruffy he had all the grace and
countenance of a chain smoking grizzly
bear and he was worth more than all the
grandmothers i never had he never talked
to me like i was stupid the way most
people talk to kids scruffy took me
seriously and he embodied unto me all
the knowledge he'd picked up in his
years in the circus trade he was a very
wise man as clowns go he never mince
words never messed around with small
talk he just jumped straight into a
conversation and expected you to catch
up i never knew what happened to the guy
i already quit the clown biz and settled
down in a nice apartment in kent i hope
he's having a good day wherever he is so
i did the juggling thing for a while
bossing around balls and bins and other
junk and catching it in my mouth
sometimes i'd put a plant in the
audience call them up and swallow them
whole as a part of the act eventually i
started working on a double act with
another freak by the name of theo see
theo could flip himself inside out but
he was also pretty skilled acrobat so
he'd do a high dive jump over the
audience before his insides outside then
aim himself down my gullet he was a
pretty great act if i do say so myself
and i even dated for a while what can i
say i find guys just as fun to swallow
as gals after he and i broke it off i
decided i needed to change up my act
that's when it hit me motormouth picture
this here's me an assistant on either
side ready to pull my mouth open then a
chrysler comes barreling into a big top
hits a ramp drives right into my mouth
into my second stomach it was a
dangerous act a magic shirt but not
immune to being run over but it was the
best act i ever came up with i could
tell you some stories about my time with
the circus oh there was this one time my
tapeworm started talking to me at the
time i was involved in overthrowing
roman follower himself and installing
ikky as a new ringmaster at the time i
hooked up with one of the non-human
capital c clowns so this is a
family-friendly channel so maybe not
that one that's not what you want to
hear though is it you'd rather hear
about how i got myself captured and
locked up by the miss scp foundation
all right why not i've already spilled
the rest of my backstory so manny you
remember manny from earlier right he
saved a lot of kids like me and when he
did he usually put me in charge of
teaching them how to perform but there
was this one girl he brought in who
broke down crying in the middle of one
of our juggling lessons she said she
wanted to go home that's when i knew
that manny had graduated from saving
runaways and abused kids like me to
abducting kids with powers of course i
confronted him about it i told him point
blank that's not how we do things
anymore herman hadn't been around for
years at this point we were better than
that gave me some garbage about him
doing what he had to do to keep the
circus alive
can you believe that even with
everything we were doing he still
thought the circus was on the verge of
collapse so i took the girl home store
there in my gut and snuck her onto the
kaleidoscope that's the machine we used
to move all the parts of the circus from
place to place the kid was back with her
pants before dinner but when i returned
to the circus manny was furious in
hindsight i think it nearly killed him
to do it but he said he had to make an
example of me so he threw me in a box
locked it with chains and painted the
words 4se on the top i was left out in
the field in camiferano japan like a rap
present for miss scp and that's how i
ended up in containment truth be told i
slept in prisons more comfortable than
this place the beds are hard the food is
gross and the little red light on the
security camera keeps me up at night not
ideal conditions for a circus superstar
of my caliber but as my old pal gordy
lantern skull used to say it's the
performer that makes the stage now go
check out threat in the game
scp-1733 season opener and scp-426 i am
a toaster for more of the downright
weirdest anomalies out there and uh
while you're here don't get me out